welcome to this video playing FM
toppling from from Denmark right yes
then one and four change I went with the
Dutch defense is playing with the quick
Knight c3 and then young going cross
Stonewall the Stonewall only should be
quite ok actually if the night is on c3
yeah white can play with the with g-form
then sets that's clear but down with the
93 make sure how dangerous this really
is oh ok maybe I need to take an early
fire first forgot about Queen h5 a
g'nite if I is going to play a queen h5
quickly ok but damn it's not the end of
the world you can can do that here 95 or
ksss terrible but this is so this is
probably ok
and threatening Knight e5 and 93 Wow
yeah okay I'm just going to damage your
pawn structure not this looks like a bat
pawn structure for white I know my
bishop is not not looking like a great
piece but still I've got a good
structure okay Queen h5 I always have g6
not not a problem if I go Quincy five
attacking c3 is going to play windy for
its not so great okay try to prepare c5
yes but I've got queen before I thought
or taking and queen before he do that he
cannot take because of Queen before so
it's basically sucking upon and I don't
mind taking it this is really just a
pawn no one particular compensation c-54
why not and Bishop c6 okay just cancel
the dominating bishop now on c6 it went
from being the dummy of this game to to
the old star piece okay now this is not
a problem it's kappa b 5 so that i can
move the bishop may be 2e form at the
right moment or d5 and then be four also
a possible continuation what i need to
be am cautious with this my king
position
if he plays age 6 or g6 and they play
the typical response h6 and I play g6 my
king is a bit backwards on the back rank
so some end games might be tricky some
something to to be cautioned with but
he's far away from from rach reaching an
end game
now my term has problems to to even find
a player will move okay let's go here
takes takes is a tempo on the Queen so
I didn't want to spend so much time
maybe there was a an even better move
but a good one is sufficient k Queenie 5
him maybe taking c3 and may be preparing
before oh I didn't see that move that's
a bit of a shame okay okay then I'm
retreating it's not not terrible the
bishop on d5 is covering eight so he has
no sacrifice or anything just he and
rook a5 may be here this looks fine
yeah I don't see him how he could
improve him to increase pressure on be
5c form I can play Queen a six and maybe
then rook yeah yeah this is what I what
I was mentioning I don't turn want to
take but right now he has got no way to
enter my my position uh-huh I was
thinking before my only hope that
all right maybe Quino let's just let's
just trade him and control the a file
what maybe it's not even exchange no
he's exchanging at the moment I don't
see ya anyway how he could could break
through okay
yeah yeah yeah this isn't this is a bit
tricky my king is really really a
problem Queen d2 went and stuff okay
Queen B so maybe and then before reckon
I I must I must push at some point I
thought I can play be three now am I
wrong I Queen a three that's sick but I
can take and at the end I happy to wear
right yes I guess check
I can play Bishop d3 no I should have
taken on c4 stead out be three Bishop d3
now Bishop d3 I can promote but he's got
Quincy seven at the end yeah what a
shame no way to play for when I guess
maybe I have pusher before sorry I'm not
turn out so quick okay
you six maybe what's so tricky time 1628
okay a plasma must promote whatever
check check yeah I guess I could check I
can escape no check oops white
four-fifths on time Babineaux no ass out
of checks and have two queens in the
attack this is was this was still tricky
somehow okay yeah the comtesse like a
minus five foot yeah it's not taking us
more precise check it still wins though
yeah I've at first I had overlooked the
smooth and this is really a way now care
yeah I round here black should win but I
mentioned before this is always risky
business this kind of this kind of stuff
was g6 computer wants to play this move
just ignoring all that don't really
understand it ah III is the problem if
he takes I recapture and I'm attacking
III with deadly infection okay yeah then
before so even the better move yeah in
general I should have considered that
because this kind of taking here or any
any search is not so terrible I mean
compared to to this some kind of
position where this pawn is always a
problem it's better to let them take all
right the interesting game I hope you
liked it thanks for watching